[Musique]
bonjour ben oui j'étais port répétition
mais je bosse quoi en fait l'air de rien
comme ça dans la vie il ya des gens qui
travaillent un peu plus que d'autres
mais c'est pas trop mon cas quoique en
fait moi je suis magali
vandemeulebroucke je suis assistante
sociale de formation
et depuis onze ans je travaille au
planning familial de d'orgueil moi je
travaille principalement avec des
adolescents
quand je vais dans leur classe quand je
vais faire ce qu'on appelle de l'everest
alors je sais pas si vous savez ce que
c'est des presses on appelle ça de
l'éducation à la vie relationnelle
affective et sexuelle en gros je dans
des classes pour parler de sexualité
baby aussi de relations affectives c'est
quoi l'amour c'est quoi l'amitié
mais très souvent on parle de sexualité
alors je travaille principalement avec
des élèves de 6e primaire je vais
traduire parce que c'est pas la même
chose à l'école européenne donc les
élèves de 6e primaire ce sont des élèves
qui vont à peu près entre 10 et 12 ans
en 2e secondaire
ils ont entre 13 et 14 ans 5e secondaire
16 19 ans oui parce que c'est un peu
plus long parce qu'on cinquième
secondaire et il regrette un peu plus
souvent donc on les voit un peu plus
souvent donc du début de l'adolescence
jusqu'à la presque fin de l'adolescence
il y en a même certains que j'ai vu en
6e primaire deuxième secondaire et 5e
secondaire j'ai vu je les ai vus devenir
des jeunes gens et puis même certains
les eiders on peut à s'affirmer à
construire quelque chose dans leur vie à
répondre à leurs questionnements alors
j'ai mes feuilles parce que je reviens
j'ai toujours tout
alors alors oui adolescence rime
généralement avec le début de la
sexualité ou des questionnements par
rapport à la sexualité vous êtes
d'accord
moi quand j'ai ça dans les classes
généralement les élèves les jeunes
adolescentes dit cela mais tu sais quand
sasha truc là dans le bas du ventre ou
comme remblais titre j'ai qu'une seule
envie c'est d'engueuler mes parents dès
que je les vois ou à un peu mieux c'est
quand je vois ce garçon là qui passent
dans la rue justin bieber ok on est
d'accord justin bieber actuellement cet
usap mais avant ils étaient comme m can
alors quoi être adolescent aujourd'hui
c'est forcément dire qu'on est un être
sexuel qu'on a une sexualité que ce soit
individuellement en couple voire plus
si on en croit kate julian qui est une
journaliste qui a fait une enquête pour
deux atlantic en 2019 et ben des
adolescents ont une vie sexuelle de
moins en moins importante par exemple
elles notent
les un recul des maternités précoces
alors certains diront bas c'est sympa
c'est bien sauf si c'était pas le
fantôme de la non sexualité des gens
elle note aussi un recul de l'âge moyen
du premier rapport sexuel en sachet en
2018 aux pays bas cet âge était de 18
ans et 6 mois
alors un truc qui vous allez dire on
s'en fout ça nous regarde pas mais aussi
un recul du nombre de rapports sexuels
dans les couples des des jeunes des
femmes de moins de 50 ans des femmes au
foyer de moins de 50 ans en 2000 ans par
exemple en grande bretagne on pouvait
dire que mensuellement des couples
avaient six rapports sexuels par mois
en 2012 ce chiffre était inférieure à 5
effet isolé quelque chose vernon il ya
des enquêtes continuent aussi fait en
australie et là on a remarqué que les
rapports sexuels descendait également
ainsi qu'en finlande
alors c'est marrant moi quand je vais
dans des classes je parle souvent de la
virginité on développe un peu ce thème
là
et des rapports sexuels et le camp je ne
mens pas à partir de quel âge vous
perdez votre virginité dans les classes
il ya toujours un grand conciliabule
ouais alors aujourd'hui brave 13 14 ans
avait monté contre toi c'est saisissait
ton est non alors ya quinze jours dans
une classe ils ont fait des calculs
savants et son arrivée à l'âge de 15 ans
rappelez vous qu
on a fait des calculs scientifiques et
c'était 18 ans et quatre mois donc d'où
vient cette différence de perception
mais en fait c'est quoi être actifs
sexuellement c'est quoi la sexualité ou
autrement dit à partir de quand on peut
dire qu'on n'est plus vierge au plus
haut alors ce toujours dans cette même
place imaginez cinquième secondaire ils
sont une dizaine des filles et des
garçons mélangés
mais tu sais bien
ouais mais si je pose la question s'est
couché pas ben c'est qu'on fait l'acte
l'acte c'est à dire eh ben
et bien c'est qu'on a fini à les
pénétrer par le mec quoi
quand elle perd son hymen
ok mais c'est quoi un email alors là
généralement dans la classe il y en a
toujours un qui est le prof de bio et
qui me sortent la définition ou qu'ils
croient être la bonne définition mais tu
sais bien c'est la petite peau à
l'entrée du vagin tu sais celle qui
scène qu'on avait fait la première fois
ces rapports sexuels
ok mais c'est quoi un email alors là ils
me regardent tous ont bien qu'est ce que
nous vous
les gars
petits secrets l'embryonnaire
l'embryonnaire bah oui en fait l'hymen
sait rien d'autre qu'un déchet
embryonnaires ça ne sert à rien ah ouais
mais ça prouve quand même la virginité
la fille
attendait
imaginez juste un petit instant une
gymnaste de 8 ans qui est sur une barre
qui fait des sauts
premier soit elle arrive deuxième saut
elle se plante elle se prend la barre en
plein dans les jambes ah oui oui je vois
des grimaces ça fait mal hélas le vagin
complètement explosé il y même disparu
alors est-elle encore vierge plus vierge
baby habitants il encore vierge
ils sont tous d'accord
tant paiement un peu des lesbiennes ben
quoi les lesbiennes mais attendez les
gars si je vous écoute bien quand ils
ont des rapports ou en toute logique
selon vous c'est pas des rapports
sexuels parce qu'il ya pas de
pénétration vaginale est ce qu'elles
sont candidats jouent pas mais là tu
exagères
attendait parce que en fait un autre
secret c'est que la sexualité ne se
résume pas uniquement à la pénétration
vaginale
et tant que je suis là moi j'ai envie de
vous dire à bas la notion préliminaire
c'est quand même terrible de ce mot là
est ce que vous avez déjà pensé sa
hiérarchie les rapports sexuels non pire
sassou tant que seule la pénétration
vaginale est importante alors que non la
sexualité n'est pas unique ali multiples
alors moi ça fait dix ans que je
travaille dans ce boulot et j'ai déjà vu
paysage on peut se modifier par exemple
vous voyez le logo lgbt
plus plus plus de plus en plus de
lettres qui s'affiche
mais moi j'ai surtout vu pendant ces dix
ans tu as des jeunes qui osent à venir
affirmé vivre quelque chose qui était
hors norme
par 10 km heure
quand je parle de normes je parle de la
norme judéo chrétienne vous savez celle
qui nous forme est depuis des siècles il
faut quand même le faire avouer demander
à des personnes vierge ou supposés comme
tels vous savez les prêtres ceux qui ont
fait voeu d'abstinence et de chasteté de
nous parler de penser la norme en
sexualité je veux dire la norme dans les
couples hétérosexuels ou la sexualité
est pensé en termes de procréation est
absolument pas en terme de plaisir non
mais alors quoi alors des adolescents
il faut quand même y aller pour vivre
quand on a une sexualité qu'un peu hors
normes dans notre société parce que tous
les jours on est confronté à ça qu'elle
se soit dans les médias meanstream ou
dans les réseaux sociaux on voit
toujours l'image parfaite le couple
parfait la sexualité épanouie parfaite
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'inflige ça
tout temps pourquoi est ce qu'on regarde
toujours ça alors je viens à utiliser
tout à l'heure mais je la réutiliser une
célèbre philosophe du 21e siècle nous a
dit non mais alors quoi arrêter
arrêtons de fantasmer la vie des autres
vivons la nôtre vous avez vous dire bon
allez gentil cela pas évident quoi quand
ado comment on fait et bien sachez qu'il
ya des gens qui n'ont fait qu'ils ont
essayé de bouleverser un peu les normes
savez les lettres lgbt kg ou plus plus
lesbien gay bi trans on dit maintenant
tu ranges ans et + transsexuels
pourra sexuelle ppour pense sexuelle
cure pour questioning écrire de plus en
plus de lettres
mois en bonne bruxelles à ce que je suis
je me suis mis mais c'est quoi ce binz
les genres elle d'être mis dans des
cases et y en a qui se créent les 15
puis j'ai lu le manchois d'avoir une
petite fille est d'observer les cadeaux
qu'elle recevait quand elle était petite
j'imagine que vous avez tous jouer avec
ça vous voyez la tortue celle où il faut
emboîter de dans les ronds dans les
ronds les carrés dans les cars et
surtout ne pas forcer les ronds pour
entrer dans les carrés parce que depuis
tout petit on apprend à catégoriser les
choses à catorive catégoriser les gens
compliqué pour moi mais alors l'exemple
le plus frappant c'est quand j'étais
enceinte les gens nous demandaient mais
vous allez les flics moment et alors à
chaque fois qu avec mon compagnon donner
un prénom et jamais le bon ça allez
comprendre pourquoi les gens ils avaient
tous une idée lb non la pause tu vas pas
dû faire ça c'est que son cadet
connaissent
elles sont super intelligente
1 elle est même pas encore nés vous la
mettez déjà dans une catégorie alors
vous imaginez bien les personnes
on pense tous à la sexualité des autres
c'est tellement plus facile
alors pourquoi se créent des catégories
pourquoi se crée des lettres
supplémentaires après lg bts et surtout
pour exister pour se revendiquer pour
s'affirmer parce que si elle écriée
c'est plus tabou c'est plus pervers et
surtout ça existe
alors vous me vois toujours ce paysage
qui changeait de plus en plus de jeunes
qui osent venir ici à borssele aux
d'organes je veux pas parler d'ailleurs
ce que je suis pas sûr que ce soit par
ailleurs mais des jeunes qui osent venir
dans les plannings familiaux venir vers
des travailleurs allez voir les médecins
des plannings parce que c'est important
ça vient tout le monde d'aller voir un
médecin c'est pas parce que vous êtes
une femme et que vous avez un rapport
sexuel avec une femme que vous n'avez
aucun risque de vous choquer des ist que
du contraire certains mettant vous
dirons nous banon n'y a pas de
pénétration vaginale
comment peuvent régner c'est donc c'est
important et puis des fois on nous parle
un peu de prévention
je vais vous sortir un premier sac
magique
on nous dit bah oui c'est important vous
prie de vous protéger
vous savez ce que c'est
ouais mais bon j'en étais certaine ça
c'est un préservatif interne ça c'est
vous mettez quand vous avant d'aller à
votre rendez-vous comme ça vous êtes sur
les protéger c'est pour les filles ou
pour les garçons ou là ne sont internes
mais les digues dans te retrouves croyez
vous qu'on trouve ça souvent
alors généralement bas on sait pas
comment on fait alors bon moi j'ai
toujours une petite boîte magique pour
moi c'est jamais pratiques dont d'accord
quand vous allez en boîte de nuit vous
n'avez jamais une paire de ciseaux sur
vous je suis d'accord ou si vous avez
une paire de ciseaux sur vous je plains
vos partenaires
les préservatifs c'est vachement plus
simple pour retrouver donc vous rappelle
on ouvre les préservatifs sur les côtés
de pelé ou ne les ouvre pas par là on ne
prend pas les dents on fait attention si
on a des ongles autres nous on fait
gaffe on découpe le préservatif et quand
on est une fille ou un mec et qu'on a
envie de faire une gâterie à sa
partenaire aucun départ on prend six 6
autres
alors ça glisse c'est pas grave alors
oui ça des conseils en fait passer un
préservatif qui ont voulu utiliser sur
un pénis 1
on prend on remet les six autres que tu
es très loin et on n'utilise a dit
angleterre qu'on veut faire un petit
plaisir à sa partenaire
oui je vois des regards interrogatifs
alors il sait pas très sexe je ne
conviens mais si ça peut vous protéger
des ist c'est pas mal hein parce que
vous souhaitez une chlamydia dans la
gorge
pas top habib ben en même temps quand
vous allez venir au planning familial
chez un médecin on va pas vous juger
c'est pas parce que vous avez eu
plusieurs partenaires sexuels que c'est
à cause de ça que vous êtes choqués nous
donnerait donc l'amiga c'est juste parce
que vous n'avez pas mis de préservatif
donc les gars on en a la distribution
prenait
alors des fois je vais aussi en
prévention dans les écoles et des fois
c'est cool parce que je vois des élèves
qui peuvent être un peu rassuré parce
que moi je suis fan de ce fait ici que
vous avez pu le remarquer mes collègues
vous le confirmeront mais les
statistiques des fois ça a du bon par
exemple
ça ça concerne beaucoup les mecs quand
je parle de la taille moyenne du pénis
parce que c'est toujours un fantasme a
shame est la mienne s est fait un
centimètre temps on hamm est de 22 cm
alors les gars
1 cuil la taille moyenne du pénis en
érection en belgique et de 14,4 cm la
circonférence et de 13,2 cm soit à peu
près un diamètre de 4 cm
alors qu'on sait qu'en voyant la taille
moyenne d'un vagin et de 14 cm ou du
rectum de 15 cm
franchement les 1% de la population ton
pénis et de plus de 20 cm j'ai envie de
vous dire vous avez quelques centimètres
en trop
mais dans le fond
vraiment est ce qu'il n'ya que les
adolescents qui se posent des questions
sur leur sexualité
parce qu'à chaque étape de notre vie on
s'en pose
quand on change de partenaire
quand on vieillit quand on a des enfants
ou qu'on essaye d'avoir des enfants ah
bin là on revient aux préceptes de
l'église qui disent qu a ouai c'est un
devoir de procréation il y en a qui
arrivent même à prendre rendez-vous pour
procréer
et toute notion de plaisir et main
balayés
quand les enfants partent de de la
maison quand vieilli
quant à des accidents la vie qu'on a une
prothèse de la hanche a vu parce qu'il
ya des fascicules qui sont faits pour
les personnes qui ont des prothèses de
la hanche pour avoir des rapports
sexuels sans avoir mal qu'en rentrant
mes entrepôts
messieurs en maison de repos vous allez
car tenez un un homme pour dix femmes
donc il faut savoir qu'il ya quelques
années
enfin de détresse a été fort maison de
repos parce que c'était là où il y avait
le plus de mst sais pas qui c'est un
autre sujet mais donc on va bien
à chaque étape de la vie à chaque moment
la sexualité est pensée elle est
construite seul ou avec son ou ses
partenaires
chaque moment on peut grâce à la
sexualité ce revivre un new beginning et
moi je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]